Canada's Syncrude Tailings is the largest.
Tajikistan Nurek is the tallest.
Brazil's Itaipu is the most powerful.
Damn dams are everywhere and they're getting
bigger all the time dammit!
Hydropower is one of the oldest methods of
power generation in the world.
Today, we often think of Hoover dam, but ancient
Greeks used the power of turning waterwheels
to grind grain.
That power was harnessed even in the early
Americas when colonists built mills on creeks
with enough drop to run waterwheels.
Today, instead of a waterwheel on a creek,
hydropower often involves building a massive
dam to hold back a water source.
With enough water pressure and drop, the water
can turn giant turbines and generate electricity.The
Department of Energy says "70 percent of Washington
State’s electricity comes from hydropower…
and 11 states get more than 10 percent of
their electricity from hydro."
The thing is, only 3 percent of the 80,000
dams in the U.S. generate electricity, and
even if they do, dams inevitably alter thousands
of square miles of waterways in both directions,
affecting fish and wildlife, forests, farms,
and (of course) human populations.
China is the largest producer of hydroelectricity,
followed by Canada, Brazil, and the United
States, according to the Energy Information
Administration.
The Xayaburi dam is a three-and-a-half billion
dollar project on the Mekong river in northern
Laos scheduled to be completed in 2019.
It's one of 11 dams planned to be completed
by 2025.
Though they'll provide 8 percent of the region's
electricity, and 3.7 billion a year in income;
it will affect more than 200-thousand people
in the region and result in "possible extinction
of fish species, reduced fish populations,
inundation of river bank gardens, and loss
of nutrients for floodplain agriculture equivalent
to 500 million dollars a year," according
to a 2011 International Rivers report.
Plus, construction of the dams could expedite
the extinction of these cute but weird-looking
Irrawaddy dolphins.
Most people are aware of the impediments these
dams make for spawning and migrating fish,
but it's not just that...
Water in a reservoir is stagnant, gathering
more sediment and growing more aquatic weeds
and algae -- causing problems with downstream
life.
Fish are used to certain temperatures and
levels of oxygen in their river water.
Dams not only block the fish, but the deep
reservoirs held by the dam result in damn
cold water with VERY little oxygen.
Opening the reservoir to respond to a sudden
demand for electricity causes this cold, barely
oxygenated water to rush into rivers, suffocating
and killing fish, this is according to the
Union of Concerned Scientists.
On top of all that, the river itself suffers,
because sand, rocks, wood and other natural
sediment builds up in the reservoir rather
than spreading downriver.
On top of ALL THAT, The Union of Concerned
Scientists found large hydroelectric dams
DO pollute with greenhouses gases.
As the reservoir behind the dam grows or floods
over plants; that material decomposes releasing
CO2 and methane; especially in tropical areas.
Emissions vary, but are just underneath the
lowest levels from a natural gas plant.
The Balbina hydroelectric dam in Brazil flooded
over 900 square miles (2360 sq km) of land
-- an area the size of Delaware, that's a
lot of decomposing vegetation.
Dams are considered symbols of human achievement
and national willpower, but that can come
at the expense of our national resources and
still cause pollution and destruction.
We didn't even talk about earthquakes or the
construction of the dams themselves -- which
can take as long as a decade.
So what can we do?
Two, century-old, dams on the Elwha River
in Washington state are blocking a key salmon
spawning channel -- and they generate very
little electricity -- so they're being demolished!
Aside from tearing them down, some hydropower
plants simply divert water rather than daming
a whole river, and you can even generate power
using natural wave surge in the ocean!
Another way companies are using nature to
power our appliances is with wind energy,
but what about when the wind's not blowing?
Then you just capture the wind in a cave and
use it later!
It sounds like a cartoon, but it's REAL.
Check out this REALLY OLD DNews video about
it here And if you love DNews, you really
should click that subscribe button, that's
how we know you're coming back to watch more.
Go ahead and do it dammit!
No, i mean, don't dam it.
But click the button.
Also come follow us on twitter!